es ist ein ausflug in die dunkelsten
abgründe der barbarei von kiew aus
bringen die busse und reporter hinaus in
die nord westlichen vororte dort hatten
sich vor dem krieg beliebte schlafstätte
entwickelt stadtnahes wohnen im
grüngürtel davon haben die russen nicht
viel übrig gelassen
unser weg führt durch trümmer wracks und
ruinen und im nächsten ausgebombten
weiler im nächsten friedlichen kiefern
hein warten die schlimmsten schrecken
des krieges
hinter uns liegt eine vierköpfige
familie die von der russischen armee
hingerichtet wurde so berichten ist die
ukraine und sie haben die weltpresse
hierhin eingeladen um zu zeigen was hier
passiert sie wollen dokumentieren welche
gräueltaten die russische armee hier
begangen hat zum sinnbild dieser greul
ist die siedlung mutter geworden vor dem
krieg heimat von etwa 30.000 einwohnern
dann wochenlang im würgegriff der russen
und was sie zurück ließen hat die ganze
welt entsetzt hunderte leichen gefoltert
und gefesselt hingerichtet ermordet und
einfach liegen gelassen
sichtlich erschüttert im angesicht
dieser brutalität der präsident
was wir hier sehen sind kriegsverbrechen
das ist reinster völkermarkt kinder
wurden getötet frauen vergewaltigt
zivilisten exekutiert
unsere reise an diese stätte des grauens
begann drei tage zuvor und 500 kilometer
westlich auf dem bahnhof von levi zu den
klängen eines patriotischen heimatliedes
dass die reisenden und die flüchtenden
für einen bewegenden moment als chor
zusammen bringt
ich kann nicht anders als dich zu lieben
meine ukraine singen sie
hier an der stelle nach polen und nach
europa kreuzen sich jeden tag die vielen
tausend kriegs schicksale eines
zerrissenen volkes
ihr eine familie auf der flucht auf dem
zerstörten mario pohl mit einer 90
jährigen großmutter die kaum laufen kann
alles ist verbrannt ich hatte sie
gebeten nicht doch dazu lassen und mich
zum sterben bereit gemacht aber dann
haben sie mich doch mitgenommen
und dort die anderen die den zug nach
kiew besteigen mutig trotzig oder weil
sie einfach nicht wissen wohin sie sonst
gehen sollen was zieht sie zurück in
ihre umkämpfte heimatstadt haben sie
keine angst
man handelt sich so im zwei wochen
rhythmus vor und denkt sich bald ist es
vorbei aber dann sind zwei wochen rum
und das geht doch weiter aber am ende
werden wir siegen da bin ich sicher
wir haben alles liegen und stehen lassen
und jetzt scheint die lage sich zu
beruhigen und da haben wir beschlossen
nach dem rechten zu sehen
diese zugreise ist nicht ungefährlich
denn jeden moment könnten die russen
angriffe auf die infrastruktur fliegen
als der abend dämmert schließt der
schaffner die fenster blenden
sonst sehen wir aus wie eine girlande
und sind ein leichtes ziel dieser waggon
und der dahinter sind schon mal
beschossen worden
beim nächsten stopp zeige ich ihnen die
splitter
deutlich verspätet aber wohlbehalten
erreichen wir kommen in eine geschundene
stadt deren nerven nach sechs
kriegswochen und in ständigen luftalarm
blank liegen in den straßen vor allem
milizionäre straßensperren kontrollen es
herrschen weiter vorsicht misstrauen und
angst manche harren seit wochen in den
schutzräumen aus notdürftig versorgt die
u bahn ist für tausende zur herberge
geworden viele verbringen die nächte
hier damit sie die kinder nicht ständig
wecken müssen wenn wieder die sirenen
heulen
wir sind alle total fertig
unsere verwandten sind an der front die
einen haben ihr zuhause verloren die
anderen sind von auswärts und stehen
völlig alleine da
dieser zeit verlangt uns allen das
letzte
aber zwischen den versuchen das erbe und
das antlitz der stadt zu schützen und in
stummen zeugen der zerstörung gibt es
auch immer wieder momente des lebens mit
der die hauptstädter nicht verlassen hat
man spürt den ungebrochenen willen sich
dem angreifer nicht auszuliefern den
hatten sie auch in borodjanka einem
weiteren vorort von kiew
heute konnten wir die stadt besuchen
aber eine stadt ist das nicht mehr
ruinen rasche brandgeruch unter den
zerschossenen hochhäusern liegen noch
viele tote berichten die bergungsteams
die trümmer tragen sie stein für stein
ab weil schweres bergungsgerät nicht
bereit steht die menschen sind zutiefst
verstört traumatisiert was sie erleben
und mit ansehen mussten wird sie niemals
loslassen das sehen wir hier ist kein
einzelfall das ausmaß der zerstörung ist
hier wesentlich größer die menschen hier
erzählen ähnliche geschichten von
gräueltaten der russischen armee
ira ist außer sich als er mir berichtet
wie die feindlichen soldaten ihre häuser
plünderten und sich in geklauten autos
voll gepackt mit diebesgut davon machten
werden sie auf die einwohner schossen
es waren tschetschenen dunkle männer mit
langen bärten und schwarzen stirnbändern
und immer haben sie nach frauen gesucht
die sie mitnehmen wollten
und ihr sohn ergänzt
verstehst du sie stellen sich mit der
knarre vor dich hin und verlangen ein
auto sie würden zivilisten ihre brüder
töten für ein auto
in der zerstörten wohnung können sie
nicht mehr bleiben was noch brauchbar
ist bringen sie fort
existenzen vernichtet zukunft genommen
ihr glück geraubt stehen sie vor dem
nichts und wissen nicht wie es nun
weitergehen soll
[Musik]